yeah you gotta have those slender
fingers slender fingers lender you can
tell player Finkle little towels on
[ __ ] pockets and you bump into him is
[ __ ] very light-footed that I am I was a
good burglar
because I could tiptoe I'm saying like
that's from my ears a tip toll on the
dummy to trying to take the wallet from
the dummy it's great that you're doing
so many different things though it's
really cool to hear you're rolling
you're doing some muy Thai and the
rolling has really improved because at
first you can't roll I dropped the
weight because I figured ferry five
pounds that'd be a little bit more
cardio plus I got the bas Rutten
mouthpiece I spoke to him yesterday
again you like that thing huh I really
believe it while you're working out or
uses what I walk you're walking when I
walk I take a walk in the morning 20-30
minutes
explain to me what it is the bas Rutten
mouthpieces on Amazon that says his
webpage I saw it because he was on Joe
talking about it I was having such a
struggle with my breathing I was having
such a struggle but it was just common
sense number one I smoked cigarettes for
20 years number two I smoked reefer for
40 years but all those are just excuses
the number one thing was the weight
every [ __ ] find then said it is some
smart guy said handsome bastard yeah he
said say want some [ __ ] handsome
he's a great guy too
he's one of the best people I know some
guys late to me the great guy a great
brown belt told me that whenever he
rolls he could feel the difference when
he's ten pounds out of it oh yeah
official is how joy whenever I go to my
mother's and I come back that first week
is Brewer like oh really and I know so
if I'm walking around at 3:09 trying to
be [ __ ] Eddie it's not gonna work so
I just started chopping on the weight I
went back to Weight Watchers
I walked in there at 3:10 now I have a
bunch of different rules now like what
you can eat what you can eat I'm gonna
tell you something you need as many eggs
as you look you in the face and tell you
something look in the face and tell you
it cause you know you and I always have
this conversation if you're heavy and
you don't go to Weight Watchers cuz
you're a [ __ ] loser whoa that's a H
that is it's that easy it's that easy
there's no idiot
you enjoy it I'm a [ __ ] idiot here
papa here papa come on
that's my god okay that's my guy so you
put everything you eat into this app
into the app oh okay
let me show you what I was I'm just
dinner snacks
total and then you you counted out by
points is that what they'd bonus they do
it themselves
not any points you get in a day 39 now
let's say Joey would you eat that give
me a can of coffee right there give me
that we don't watch pink okay we don't
know so you scan that and then it'll
tell you how many I don't think that has
many calories it does coffee plain
coffee of calories not really maybe a
couple but not really so when you get
the [ __ ] milkshake coffees for
breakfast and cheeky and the [ __ ]
flat white even a flat white don't kill
you all right this isn't in there it's
not even let you go like this boom and
then you got this Joe Rogan you ready
you press this over here and you press
this here and you press this here and
they give you points for whatever you do
walk circuit training then you have
custom so I press Brazilian Jujitsu
let's play you go to an hour class how
much do you really [ __ ] roll
15 minutes fuel in our class you don't
technically take you gotta do the drill
and he tells you a joke so you're
pressing 15 done and then you press the
intensity will you breathe like an atom
I just bet seven points mmm you leave
this in your phone watch it
you put this in your pocket and [ __ ]
guess what happens it counts two steps
when I went to Disneyland let that burn
31 [ __ ] points so it's all the
exactly for breakfast so for breakfast I
go to John's and I gotta I see the roll
even if I give myself for [ __ ] points
for the roll five points for the roll
six points for the roll
I put two eggs in that [ __ ]
which is 14 grams of protein hmm and I
put a thin slice of thumanns boy's head
American cheese and some Frank's hot
sauce on that [ __ ] hey they're
talking so you essentially could eat
anything you want as long as you know
what the points are a certain amounts
fish i couldäôt fish
days so I'll leave here and go to
[ __ ] sushi Dan and I get the crunchy
albacore which is I can't wait for Rogan
to visit me it's sliced albacore covered
with jalapeno
onion and garlic close is it possible
let me ask you this is it possible that
you could eat just all eggs all day and
have zero points zero points really
eggs old days all day that sounds crazy
fish all day sea bass you can eat salmon
and sea bass all day chicken breast no
skin no small [ __ ] day all day
chicken breast not chicken cutlets like
mom made with Italian breadcrumbs
no no that's fried grilled chicken on
the breast with red crushed peppers and
a baked potato five points for the baked
potato ooh
so you want to tell me again how and
listen you know it's not a Jay it's not
a [ __ ] race see before it's only
healthy to lose like a pound a pound and
a half a week is that what it is that's
what they say anything after that you go
on in to that loser show where they lost
all that weight at one shot and then
that's why all these diets and stuff
that you have to do or something you're
gonna do forever I've always liked this
I lost 100 pounds with this yeah
and then I gained 40 and now I lost
another 30 that's awesome and it hasn't
been killing me like I don't miss
nothing you know what I've learned I
didn't know this I would go get an
outside eye ball
American thinks an acai ball is great
let me explain something to you eating a
banana and putting a banana in a blender
it's two different things I did not know
that one day I was making one of those
because I switch I have Hollett protein
from which I used a vanilla or the
chocolate Mexican chocolate mm-hmm and
then I have this other one that's a
poleo type protein that's coconut milk
and I put I use that one and one there
so let me put a banana in this
[ __ ] just to see it I'm like
damn it's delicious I'm on to something
I gained weight that week I didn't know
what it was from the banana when you
blend a banana it's eight points but
when you eat a banana
it's who gods but it's
manaphy because when you eat fruit and
when you drink fruit it's two different
things that's why all these fat people
when you see them going I don't eat
breakfast I drink a smoothie you're
killing yourself you were killing
yourself every time you puree fruit
because when you eat fruit the sativa
the sitar the saliva saliva sativa god
forbid the saliva in your mouth breaks
the fruit down and the digested the
sugar a different way mmm when you
bypass that enzyme in your mouth that's
what you get 300 pounds and uncle Joey
all right so when you drink fruit I
don't care if they tell you oh it's
frozen fruit you lose some of the sugar
that's [ __ ] once you [ __ ] blend
that fruit you dead because it goes
right into your system do you sit down
all the fiber
I collect wha yeah you're not supposed
you learn that [ __ ] any other way other
than the way that comes when you eat it
you can go to that [ __ ] little
Mexican stand with the umbrellas you
ever see those guys the cartel delivery
yeah that's what the cartel drops wrote
that money shake them down
I got three hundred thousand under that
guy's only cut the fruit with a machete
Greg I dare you to go up there when you
see a cartel umbrella that that's a
cartel money that they got tons of money
in those things they just confuse people
they even got them across the street
from one another well that Starbucks